all right malicious malicious malicious
where where you from originally um New
Orleans Louisiana New Orleans yes tell
me about your family growing up in orle
okay so I grew up as a middle child of
like five siblings um my mom was there
my dad died early on but around the age
of nine my mom remarried it didn't
really have much of an effect on my life
I was really young for most of it don't
really remember most of it you know what
I mean you go through any rough times
your
I wouldn't think so I actually had quite
a nice life I quite think compared to
like other people like I didn't really
realize until I was like in like maybe
fifth grade and I would go to other
people's houses and like they would have
less stuff than me you know it would be
people sharing rooms me and my siblings
we always kind of had our own
room or if we had shared the room like
we always had our own sides you know we
always had our own stuff what kind of
teenager were you uh I wouldn't say I
was rebellious but I definitely um was
quiet for most of my life and observing
so I learned how to articulate myself
very well early on in life so I when I
was a teenager I just felt like I was
very I was very vocal with most of my
opinions you know what I mean still am
sadly when did you come to California uh
first time like um in like January so
you're new here where you from are you
are you based in La uh no I'm based in
Vegas you're in Vegas yeah you're just
working Figaro Street for the week um
you know dible and Dabble dribble you
travel around dribble and travel dible
and Dabble you know you travel around of
course what what cities have you been uh
Arizona Vegas and um La I keep it like
really on the west side I try to avoid
it as much as possible you know I just
do it every so now with then get some
money how long you been doing this uh
for like a year how how'd you get
introduced to it um so uh my mom moved
like back to New Orleans when I was like
18 right around the time I graduated so
like ever since then I kind of was like
on my own um and then I was like
donating plasma and stuff doing stupid
stuff like that you know and it got me
sick a lot so I started like trying to
like rap and stuff you know what I mean
so I wouldn't say trying to rap I
actually can rap I have a great ability
to do it I just wouldn't like I was too
I'm too picky by my music I want to make
sure that everything's perfect when I
you know put it out and everything so it
was like I was very very like um
hesitant on putting it out but I met
someone in the studio and that guy
pretty much we ended up being entangled
for a cool minute and pretty much I
ended up you
know yeah be introduced to this around
December I got entangled with him around
like maybe three four months before what
do you think of this this line of work
uh at first I I didn't really know what
quite to think about it because I was I
knew I was around it but my my family's
always was very careful to keep me out
of it as a child because um in the South
it's it's a very high like value in my
family especially that you know you
always present yourself as a lady no
matter what you do you know what I'm
saying so a lot of the things it was
really well covered so I didn't even
know about a lot of it until I was older
how old you now I'm 19 I'm really you're
yeah so you're still a kid yeah of
course but I'm going to be 20 next month
on the 5th so literally like next
month does your family know you're doing
this uh my mom does and I don't really
care who else does like or doesn't know
you know I mean I'm doing it at the end
of day just surv five you know what I'm
saying like when you work a 9 to5 you
get paid like 975 an hour in my first
job and I work my ass off and work
overtime just to go and get like $2 $300
a check and then I would have to go to
school and work my ass out there and it
was very tiring I almost didn't make it
through High School actually because it
was like I would have to like um take
off of shifts to go to school or take
off of school to go to shifts you know
what I mean so but it it it it it I I I
disciplined myself very well so it
worked out you know what I'm saying but
you know doing this you get paid like
you know
$400 sometimes on a good night in Vegas
for like 15 minutes with a guy you know
what I'm saying just just a guy that
just wants to talk to you you know chat
it up and then other times you getting
paid like you know $1,000 to do some
crazy [__] like you know [__] on a guy
or like walk on him or let him lick the
bottom of your shoe like some guys like
weird stuff like you know I charge like
$300 for a guy to take my panties on the
blade you know um I don't charge less
than 20 usually um if a guy really
doesn't have anything then I'll take a
pack of condoms you know like and yeah I
get I could get some money for that and
I'll give them my number but I don't
really give out or exchange my time for
anything that's not money you know what
I mean if it's not talking about money
you could just meet me another time you
know what I'm saying so it was very easy
to get into this I've always been
flirtatious I was always intimate I just
didn't really I guess I wasn't expecting
the weirdos you know what I'm saying so
yeah that kind of takes a toll on your
mental sometimes were you addicted to
the fast money now uh it's not really
that I'm addicted to it I've stopped
like twice you know and I stopped for a
cool couple of months it's more like it
follows me I would say like like I'll be
walking down Maryland Parkway and the
guy come up to me like oh you're very
cute you're attractive and this has
always happened like all throughout my
life you know guys like try to like stop
me in the cars like oh you're very
attractive do you need a ride and I'll
be like you know like when I was younger
I'm a child you know what I'm saying and
they wouldn't really care and I just
like no good but I don't know I guess it
was when I first did it I got like
$480 and ever since then it was like why
the [__] go get paid 975 you
know but you know it it's definitely not
an easy business at all but what are the
what are the downsides of it what's what
the hardest parts about doing this every
day you're risking your life you know
what I'm saying every car you get into
every play that you make you know
there's guys like I've literally like
I've been stabbed in the stomach you
know what I'm saying there's guys that
literally will like try yeah they'll try
to kidnap you they'll try to rob you you
know and it's it's it's very important
that you like you don't do this alone
it's not an industry where you want to
like I'm not saying every girl should be
with the pimp if the pimp is abusive or
not you know what I mean but if you know
if a guy stresses you out choose your
peace same thing to The Pimps you know
if a girl stresses you out choose your
peace but in the in the rare occasion
that you do find a very good man who
does want to you know involve himself in
your life and benefit off of you and you
benefit off of him because at the end of
the day um every woman or every woman in
his business you know needs guidance at
the end day we all have problems we all
have habits of spending you know what
I'm saying every woman there not a woman
I don't know I love spending my money on
like clothes shoes bags and if I'm
holding my own money it's not going to
be saved in the right way you know what
I mean whereas um with a pimp you at
least you know you know like um you know
with the right guy with the right pimp
you know some real pimping not not what
no [__] not no you know a guy that's
really there to profit so he's going to
make sure that you profit because as
long as you're good he's good you know
what I mean like you know Mone could
make though if you could do this without
a pimp and not spend it on well r out
there and you're on the streets and then
a pimp pops out his car and follows you
all the way up the block and starts
tearing off your clothes or doing
whatever you know not saying every pimp
does that but um you know there there
are guys you know they're gangs blades
that run through gangs you know what I'm
saying and there are guys that will go
around and Rob females just like Vegas
or Arizona uh I would say it's not
because Vegas and Arizona everywhere
that you could play out there it's very
heavily like um you know policed I would
very much still say like but here but
here on fig it's um it's different it's
still policed you know what I'm saying
you just got to the gangs are thick yeah
so that's that's what it is mainly for
fig I feel like the police are really
there more worried about everyone's
safety rather than like you know that's
it's existed for so long it's like we
know that we have to shut it down
eventually but right now you know we're
more why is this happening to the
community and you know I feel like the
police is just trying to figure out why
is it happening and what's going on with
it you know what I'm saying rather than
like trying to take every girl to jail
you know I mean they're just trying to
figure out like you know help but you
know girls don't want help from police I
don't feel like any woman that's really
you know a 304 whatever want help from
police you know I mean I take it drugs
are not a part of your life uh I do
marijuana and that's about it shrooms I
don't do any of the hard stuff you stay
away from it it's very easy to not get
hooked on it you know what I mean black
don't crack especially if you don't
smoke black or
crack tell me about the customers you
have um usually like they're older men
you know um sometimes it's really
good-looking men and you know they just
don't want to like go through the whole
phase of having to pretend to really
like a girl and Court a girl and spend
all that money just have sex they would
just rather get it fast sometimes it's a
guy that's just you know driving around
and you know just see and just you know
he's like oh you're fine and then
sometimes you got guys that really just
do this on a regular day-to-day basis
you know come outside with like
$500 and you know spend it on talking or
spend it like on stupid stuff you know
maybe they just enjoy the girl you know
sometimes guys really fall for the girls
out here and they just want to see them
okay they just want to see them good
help any way that they can you know what
I'm saying have you had guys who got to
attached to you yeah I really used
usually like cut them off they kind of
creep me out just a little bit you know
I'm very young and even though I'm a
very powerful woman I'm very much so
aware of the workings in this world I
would like to consider myself a
Christian woman even though I know this
this may not be the most Godly you know
line of work I still know that I'm
sinning I still know that I'm doing
wrong so I very much still still believe
in God you know what I'm saying I pray
every day and I I believe that I've been
kept safe because I don't do grimy
things you play by the rules of the book
it's very easy to get very far in this
game I mean if you you just got to play
by the rules you step out of pocket you
step out of line you risking everything
you know what I'm saying so every day
that you get out there is is really it's
really not a joke it's so many different
things that could happen out there you
know what I mean so you just got to
really have your head on the swivel you
got to really have live in that press
moment you can't think about anything
else you can't be stressed out that's
what I'm saying so it's
like most of the time Girls Just Want to
get a pimp someone to share someone to
vent with someone that's going to
understand them because it's like
usually when you get a square boyfriend
you know what I'm saying they don't
really want to share you they don't care
they just feel like okay like why are
you doing this I can provide for us and
even if that is the case like no 304 is
really going to be satisfied living off
of another man cuz at the end of the day
we all secretly like well I don't feel
like we all but I secretly just feel
like I never want like to depend on a
man and a man like see me at my lows and
try to put me down you know what I'm
saying so I always have to have my own
I've been raised like that that's the
type of woman I've been raised to be you
know I mean but with the pimp it's like
that's our companion you know I mean he
understands exactly what's going on in
the game he understands exactly what
moves to make exactly what play to play
so make sure that you get home safely
usually but sometimes you know there's
the rarecation where guys you know they
don't they all in it for themselves you
know what I'm saying and on those
occasions I just I don't know if you
just stay in Pocket if you start off
with a really nice guy and you just stay
in Pocket you'll be fine it's when
you're like a [__] you know like a
girl that like chooses many guys you
know you'll never have anything really
stable unless you really like stay down
for your crown really stay down stay
into this you know what I mean because
at the end of day if you don't stay
disciplined if you don't stay every day
you know going hard then you get lazy
and you fall off it's very easy to get
lazy you know what I mean and then the
money's not flowing
there's there's many different kinds of
pimps oh yes very very many different
kinds of pimps and many different kinds
of hoes you know what I'm saying but I
would recommend that every woman like
every girl out here if they don't have a
pimp they have some form of protection
you know what I'm saying at the end of
the day always nearby you know cuz um
it's it's a very dangerous game every
single day I hear different things every
single day I see different things and I
haven't encountered not the worst of it
I don't even think so you know what I'm
saying saying but I've encountered quite
a good bit you know but I try to
remember that just like God works every
day and send blessings the devil tries
to send evil your way you know what I'm
saying so those those mishaps those
hiccups I just feel like that was the
devil trying to deter me you know trying
to steer me from God you know what I
mean but at the end of the day if if you
really you know you believe in the
higher power you believe in what you're
doing you know hopefully this is just a
stepping stool it's not really a career
it's just a stepping stool to get in get
out you know I mean sometimes guys take
it as a career Sometimes women take it
as a career but for me at least I just
consider it like a stepping stool I get
in I get it I get out a lot of people
tell me they don't even see me out there
I'm out there every day you know I mean
if not every day then I'm somewhere else
you know what I mean I'm making some
type of money you work every day of the
week uh you have to you have to as a
woman I feel like once I sit down for
maybe two three days I get naturally
lazy you know if I break out of my
routine you know if I don't find
something something to occupy myself
even if it's something as simple as like
you know um not washing my face before I
go to sleep leaving my makeup on you
know and that becomes repetitive thing
and then it's really hard to um break
that cycle I feel like with women it's
very much so easier for us to you know
get into that state of um nuzzling like
I don't even know that's a word but like
comfortability to where like you know we
just we don't care sometimes you know
what I'm saying so I I like to get up
every day and go hard even if I'm not
doing that you know I'm doing something
else to you know better myself I'm in
the gym or I'm you know I'm modeling or
I'm doing something you know or well I
don't really I don't have any agencies
or anything but I do be doing photo
shoots and stuff you know like I take
pictures with um my photographer friends
and for them sometimes you know what I'm
saying and you know sometimes I find
like you know places that sell clothes
for my you know choice of
employment that want to like videotape
me and stuff you know it's all is there
a romantic aspect to your relationship
with your pimp um it's it's it's usually
supposed to be you know what I mean I
feel like with me I'm a very submissive
woman because I was raised in the South
I grew up in a family where it's either
you shut the [__] up and you stay in
your place or else not even like just
the people around you you know remind
you of that because at the end of day my
family was raised on principles of they
they'll touch you before the streets do
you know what I'm saying before you get
too far out they'll touch you so it's
like you you stay respectful no matter
what to your elders so it's like for me
I'm a very submissive woman I don't like
to argue with my pimp or anything you
know what I'm saying so I just trust
that you know basically he has my best
interest at heart you know what I'm
saying not not saying like I'm
manipulated or anything but I just trust
that he genuinely has my best interest
at heart just because I know like the
type of man he is and when a woman
respects their man it it it it shouldn't
be no hiccups it shouldn't be no Sorrows
you know what I mean and if it is some
Sorrows then at least you know no matter
what like good bad or angry you know
that's a man that I know I can sleep
next to and I'm going wake up tomorrow
and he's still going to be there no
matter what you know what I'm saying and
the best thing that you could do is just
if you know you got a man like that try
to reciprocate that energy you know what
I mean that way every day you know it's
it's a very hard game every every pimp
need one good [__] you know what I mean
and every good every [__] no matter how
good she is no matter how much money she
make ain't going to feel satisfied
unless you know she got someone to share
that with you know what I'm saying so
that's how I feel feel about it you go
get a pimp maybe you go get he go got
wifey maybe already or you go get some
and you know now you're not on the blade
alone you got females out there you know
what I'm saying you you know you being
washed over it's it's a very more it's a
much more safer feeling that I would
have to say than being out there alone
just from my experience you know what
I'm saying because I've had guns put to
my head and some more stuff you know
what I mean it's it's it's definitely
not for the week you it's very tricky
you have to play yourself in your cards
very well you know what I mean have to
watch yourself at all times
do you see you see men differently since
you've been doing this for a while um so
no I've always I I waited till 18 to
have sex so I picked my first time out
at 15 and I was with my first love for
like four years long distance and it was
just more of like um every man that I
was with longterm they like kind of just
wanted to sleep around so it it's like
okay most of the girls around my age
just sleeping around anyway I get horny
I got real bad hormones so it was just
like why not make money off of it you
know what I'm saying but now I don't
really have sex outside of it you know
what I'm saying if I'm not getting
payment it's like really no like unless
it's with my pimp you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah it's going to be hard
for you to go back to a a normal
romantic relationship uh I wouldn't
think so unless the guy's giving you
lots of money but it's like uh I want to
be secure on my own that's what it is
but I definitely believe that if a man
wants to lay me on my back he should
definitely have some investments in me
you know what I'm saying no guy like
there's a thousand one woman out here
and in my family in specific you know
what I'm saying like all over but like I
know in my family for sure like in the
South up here in the west coast there's
a lot of women that are having kids by
these men that don't have no investment
in them other than that kid you know I
mean never bought you a chain never
brought you a purse never took you out
to a nice dinner never really treated
you well so those women into that habit
of like um neglecting themsel because
they get used to being neglected you
know what I'm saying at the end of the
day I grew up with a daddy that um you
know and even if my daddy was there my
mom you know if I if I really need it
and my mom always made sure it was done
you know what I'm saying I never really
had to ask you know what I'm saying so
it's like when when I feel like for men
and for women when you have a
significant other when you get
married that's like that person taking
that parents place so like my daddy
hands me off that's he's handed in his
my his leadership role of my life over
to you know my significant through my
husband you know what I'm saying so it's
like if if I don't know for sure like if
I if I got washed up today like with all
the money that I have and everything you
know or if I don't have money you know
what I'm saying no matter what I want to
be with somebody that's going to love me
and be able to take care of me you know
what I'm saying not at the same token I
don't feel like women that aren't
submissive should be able to ask that
same thing you know what I'm saying
women that aren't like I'm not saying
shut the [__] up and listen to
everything your man says but
definitely try to hear where he's coming
from listen listen to understand not to
respond that's the problem that I like
not even just before this game like you
know as a teenager I was like very angry
very hurt at a lot of things I went
through a lot of grievances in my family
so it was like you know I I had learned
like a lot of the time I was hurt at
things that was happening inside of me
and it cost me to have Outburst in life
you know at the people that I love the
most so when I learned how to control my
temper even people that deserve it you
know they don't really deserve to see
you know me exhaust that much energy
like if it was really worth my time then
I would take a look at it but it's not
worth it like the chances of going to
jail and stuff you know it's really not
worth it a lot of the time so I just
stay out of the way you know what I mean
that's that's that's how it would
usually be for me emotionally what do
you go through you get depressed at all
it's ups and downs sometimes you're very
happy sometimes you think about the life
that you had before you know what I mean
do you have
regrets do I have
regrets um yes and no because at the end
of the day I know when I started doing
this I didn't have anything you know
what I mean I didn't have nothing
besides enrolling in like college that
was pretty much the only option for me
and so like when I did that it was like
yeah financial aid covers so much but
there's still so much that I have to
cover and then on top of that my mom's
not in the same state as me so it's like
I was really I was really doing it all
on my own so it was
like either do this or really be outside
you know what I'm saying like did you
have dreams of doing something with your
life um I still can life and I'm still
going to do something with my life I'm
very much so still going to be in
college I'm very much so still pursuing
every path that I want to pursue like I
said this for me is not my career this
is a stepping stone if I come back in 10
years you won't be doing this anymore oh
I doubt it if I'm doing it in five I'm
not going to lie why but um you know
there's there's definitely women that
take this very seriously that that's
their whole life you know what I'm
saying that they've been doing this
since a very young age and they they
know the ins and outs of the game and I
and I really feel like a lot of people
get a lot farther if they just shut the
[__] up and listen a lot of the time you
know I mean oh I'm sorry if that was
disrespectful but you know like just you
know be quiet and really observe you
know what's going on around you before
you really speak and let people know you
know what's on your head and what's what
you thinking you know I'm saying like I
say some [__] before I say what I'm
actually feeling you know I'm saying
like a lot of my friends I'm known as
that friend that has no filter and
that's mainly just because like one I
have ADHD so I just be thinking of
random [__] and like to like I would
just rather if I'm around people that I
know I'm not comfortable with I would
rather say some [__] then you know
actually be vulnerable and then it's
like yeah you spent 30 minutes with me
but you spend 30 minutes of knowing what
nothing you know what I
mean do you have regulars that you kind
of call you often of course you know
what I mean I'm a very sweet girl I'm
charismatic and that's why I feel like a
lot of females Miss in this game a lot
of girls walk out there every day they
mad soggy tittied [__] face drooping
you know what I mean if you just walk
into it with positivity every day you
know what I'm saying with or without
drugs with or without whatever the [__]
you coping with you know walk into that
[__] with positivity on your brains then
it's going to have nothing but positive
outcomes you know what I'm
saying so it's like yeah I have regular
that call me every every freaking day
you know I mean I have regulars that see
me twice a week I have regular that see
me once a week I have regulars that when
they can't see me they'll pay me for
like sex videos instead you know what
I'm saying I've i' I very very very like
you know I have very nice men they take
care of me and I like to take care of
them you know what I'm saying I don't do
or service any man that I don't feel
comfortable taking care of if I feel
like I have to get outside of my
character just to be around a man it
makes no sense because at the end of day
that's when they're out of line and I'm
not going to put myself through dealing
with a man when I don't have no kids
what's your what's your favorite kind of
guy favorite kind of
trick I like men that spend over $500
cuz everybody likes to say everybody's a
trick just because a man spending some
money on some coochie does not make a
man a trick some men just want it the
easy way you know what I'm saying
so it's like at the end of the day you
got to realize money is very obtainable
in this world so it's like $100 is
nothing $200 is nothing that's like $1
$2 but a man that comes out with at
least $800 in his pocket and can really
oh spend $500 here and still afford to
go see another woman that's a real trick
because at the end of the day he came
out with nothing else on his mind but
seeing you know those [__] and that
that's that's my favorite kind you know
what I'm saying not saying like they
they suckers but you know they suck us
for some [__] you know what I'm saying
for some 304s if you know how to you
know do what you do very very well you
know what I'm saying you know man going
to take care of you take care of your
bills take care of your ring you're
never going to have to worry how do you
think doing this kind of work is
changing you
uh I very much so see The Good the Bad
and the Ugly you know what I'm saying um
and I really do feel like it really does
take a toll on my mental sanity
sometimes because I really see how the
devil you working you know what I'm
saying and I'm nobody don't have to
believe in God you know what I'm saying
but if you believe in the bads of this
world if you see the bads of this world
if you see the evil I would pray that
everybody finds you know something
positive to at least you know vent to
you know what I'm saying or hope any
positive lining in life you know what
I'm saying because I then day people
going out here [__] around doing
stupid [__] every day you got to believe
that there's people out here that's
working for positivity you know what I'm
saying
so is is it really just it's all about
survival for me you know what I mean for
me it is you know what I mean it's it's
easy money you know what I'm saying it's
fast money and it's not easy money but
when you when you having a good day is
it's very easy sometimes it's hard are
you a hustler of course always always
had to hustle selling silly bands in
third grade you know the little the
bands that like you take them off your
wrist and they was like little shapes 25
cents what advice would you give a young
girl who's thinking about doing
this don't I'm not going to cap um it's
it can it can take a toll on you I would
recommend like if you if you can do
anything else try everything else first
you know what I mean and then if this is
the last option then you know do what
you got to do to survive at the end of
the day but don't let this become you
don't let this make you into a different
person than you started off as you know
what I'm saying I I believe that I'm
still the same person I started off fast
yes I've gained wisdom yes I've I've
learned how to you know interact with
people and I've actually learned how to
see through a lot of [__] a lot
better now that oping this and it's
allowed me to stay away from a lot of
Chaos in my life so it's like every
interaction you just got to make sure
that
um you just got to make sure like that
you make the best out of it you know if
you if it just comes down to you having
to do this but if you can do anything
else do everything else you know what I
mean this should not be any little
girl's dream you know what I mean this
should not be something that is very
worship and idolized like it is in
today's society yes every every female
should want to eventually settle down
and nurture because that's in our
instincts you know what I mean we should
want a man that we know like if we do
have this baby he's going to take care
of me no matter what you know and take
care of this baby no matter what how I'm
feeling how we feel you know what I
mean but you
know malicious what would you say say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your
life have you take L's as lessons and
not losses then a lot of M come after
you know what I mean every single thing
that challenged you in your life it's
all about perspective and how you take
it I I was a very depressed kid you know
what I mean there was times where I self
torm and it wasn't even like I was
getting abused or anything it was mainly
just because I felt like I didn't really
fit in nowhere cuz I'm very I'm I'm I'm
multiracial you know what I mean so um
in my city I would get told I like to
talk like a white person dress like a
white person act like a white person and
then whenever I go around like you know
white people like my white family
members you know I get tell quite the
opposite you know like I act ghetto I
act ratchet you know what I mean so it
was just like a lot of my life I was
like I I was like alone so it really
forced me to take my schooling very
seriously take everything that I do very
seriously so now I take everything I do
very serious you know what I'm saying
very disciplined so you know stay
disciplined take all your losses don't
let that [__] change you don't let that
[__] like take an impact on your ego
take a hit on what the [__] you got
going on you know what I mean keep going
you stumble you trip get the [__] up
take the shoes off find some new ones
that fit keep running my [__] you know
what I mean sometimes shoes get worn out
you got to try something else you know
you can't you can't you can't let the
bottom of your feet burn you know what
I'm saying you got to keep going you got
to keep keep stepping got to keep
stepping always always all right
malicious thank you so much for sharing
your story no problem no problem you
lots of luck out there stay out of
trouble
okay